[Applause]
thank you everybody
welcome
to vcon
[Applause]
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
i'll just make a video
all right
this is my future home
i'm just gonna live here
the flea market
but this
this is my spot i'll see all of you
you'll all be
over here oh there's a ferris wheel
they'll be all v conning but i'm gonna
be
signing like a [ __ ] right here
table 40. could we make it table 55
that's where i'm gonna be
this audience is so happy to be with
each other that i think we're gonna win
that game i think we have a lot of
latitude a lot of good will and a lot of
happiness in the air so i feel overall
incredibly confident
impersonators
they're gonna go on they've three to
five minutes how many are there two
there's two who is it it's nima and who
nemo is gonna come out yep and he's
gonna come out as you i understand right
and then he'll be interrupted by ami and
if we don't zoom in on omni and the imax
i think he's gonna come out looking like
he loves this all right
how long do they have
three to five minutes if you feel like
this isn't working it's bombing you
gotta get out there it's definitely not
gonna bomb those guys are more popular
than i am now
they're gonna be so people are gonna
love it i'll let them do their thing
yes
they'll deal with the improv nature of
me coming on when i want to come on
cool thank you everybody
i highly recommend everybody be here
for doors opening at eight so like even
7 45 lining up is probably a good idea
get your sleep everyone
[Music]
just incredibly focused on everybody
deploying as much kindness to each other
as humanly possible being the bigger
person for this entire weekend is the
mantra
please make friendships please make
memories i'm glad you're here
[Music]
when i launched the friends last may
most people really had no idea what was
going on in this world i knew the most
interesting thing about nft land was not
the front-facing
visual aspect the art the collectible
which i love i come from a collecting
sports cards comic book store so it came
very natural to me the psychology of why
this is all working the most interesting
part about nft land is the smart
contract it's what's attached to the
image in the contract of the collectible
i said you have a ticket to three years
worth of a conference called vcon
and that's what we've brought here to
minnesota this year if i can get
one person in this room to actually
spend 15 to 20 hours
of reading
or listening on a podcast i really
really want all of you to learn it not
because i want you to buy a v friend or
collect something else like a board ape
or a world of women or other cool stuff
but because there's 0.0 chance that this
technology doesn't affect you
[Music]
vcon hasn't even started yet and i have
more friends here than in my own city
let's go dude i saw this photo on
twitter
yo i'm just here with the boy garyvee
here
in 2022 nfg cobb barracuda is in the
building
oh you can't even get it yeah oh man
dude
oh my god this is crazy
all right at the welcome party set up
there's the stadium we'll be all weekend
felocious is
our party
i know aj will be there because he's
super good at cornhole
drock's here oh look at it i see it the
selfie station the volunteers and look
look how good looking the volunteers are
that's where i'll be living
so if you're looking for me that's where
i'll be living
[Music]
that's where i'll be living
looking forward to it tonight
what's up gang what you're doing thank
you bro
thank you guys see you later gary nice
to meet you nice to meet you huge fan
thank you for being at the park over
here and i saw you guys over here i was
actually drawn that's [ __ ] amazing
yeah would you mind with all right if
you just signed up here if that's what i
want to do i would really appreciate
that i'm happy to do it bro yeah
appreciate one everybody coming here
what would you say
bring happiness
awesome see you guys later
[Music]
somebody who lives so much in the
digital space yes why an in-person
conference the world is not or it's and
my favorite thing is people
and and why i love digital unlike a lot
of people who are like digital's not
real you have to do it in person i don't
agree with that i've built many
relationships here
through digital first as a gateway to
then the physical and so i believe in
both
and so i definitely wanted to do a
physical conference
wow that's crazy pretty cool
all of the good stuff comes from
listening the reason my content's fairly
unique is because i read my dms see what
people are actually feeling and then
make content but it led to a whole
content pillar for me for a couple years
that really mattered that would have
never happened if i didn't read all the
dms we should be listening to every
single reply to every piece of content
in fact i produced a lot of content just
to get comments to give me insights to
questions i have
[Music]
it's really
all right thank you
hailing
uh
reporting live from v-con
it's hailing
they don't know that you're coming what
they don't know that you're crazy
[Applause]
when i came in to be friends i
personally didn't even think about being
a woman and feeling like oh i didn't
feel included like i didn't even think
about that you did such a well job like
at feeling making all of us feel
included and so now we're just trying to
continue that on here and uh we're very
glad to have everyone show up
[Applause]
[Music]
the entire
totality of the v friends community has
already brought in just a couple of
hours to minnesota
is uh is being felt locally and that's
the most beautiful thing so i hope you
have a great time uh i'll see all of you
pretty soon here at the party it seems
like i know you've been inside but it's
been hailing like a [ __ ] outside
uh but thank you for following me up
here i just wanted to stop by and say
thank you and congrats and all that and
hope everybody has the best four days
i'll be seeing you a whole bunch
cheers
bye guys what's good thanks for coming
nice kicks brother
little update for tomorrow based on what
i'm seeing from people entering right
now the welcome party if you can help
not having a bag tomorrow
that's like a real good idea
let me speed it up
cool see ya
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
i'm telling everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna go say hello to a couple give
me one second
yo
thank you
thank you for waiting in line so we'll
get to real quick we got it open thank
you so nice to meet you thank you for
coming
okay we'll be right back is that hey
what's up
things are good how are you man where
are we going okay
i got to go to the front
yard
gary
what's up just want to say thank you
thank you for waiting we got you we got
you coming in be up in a minute thank
you for coming thank you for waiting
live thank you bro thank you thank you
sorry for the week
i'm happy you're here
thank you say shout out mr ford mr ford
i know who the [ __ ] you are but shout
out to you he put me on to you it's
awesome you look great tonight thank you
[Music]
i've been dreaming about this moment
since 2016. we did it what's your name
my friend amit i'm from israel i flew
all the way from tel aviv to here i want
to give you my t-shirt is it okay yeah
yeah i'll take it okay i appreciate you
so much thank you brother have the best
weekend the main event
um just how proud i am of my brother you
know i want you guys all to know
that this energy that you're bringing
this positivity that you're bringing
that's what energizes him that's what
feeds him so i'm just so happy
for him i'm so happy for this community
that we're able to get together and i
just want to say thank you so without
further ado
the guy
that is at the center of this entire
thing going on right now
my brother gary vaynerchuk
[Applause]
thank you everybody
welcome
to v-con
[Applause]
uh first huge shout out for the people
still in line i [ __ ] see you i love
you get in here
we got you uh i want to uh
thank so many people
but
most of all i want to thank my family i
want to thank my team there's so many so
many people that make something like
this happen
from the macro of great parenting to the
micro of the people in the trenches with
me every single day that you get to see
a little bit here and there because of
the way we roll but there's many more
that you don't get to interact with most
of all i want to thank this collective
group of people and let me tell you why
the overwhelming feedback
of just how kind
and positive this collective group of
people have been in this town in the 45
seconds that we've been here means that
we're capturing the energy of what this
is all about that's right there's a lot
going on with this project over the next
four or five decades but the biggest
one the biggest mission at hand
is to try to leave the world in a better
place than we entered and that is my
plan
that is my mission
i'm incredibly grateful humbled i'm
gonna save my [ __ ] for tomorrow morning
i've got a lot of selfies to take i love
this community from the bottom of my
heart thank you i'm humbled i will see
you tomorrow have a great [ __ ] time
tonight i love you
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
before we let you go i really want to
find andy can you guys help me find andy
can everyone just say andy
andy is at the front making sure we're
getting people in let's stop focusing on
this silly stuff let the man operate and
b a and d and d let's go ski
[Music]
cap you can make change don't change for
that tell the whole truth get paid for
that but you never fall off you was made
for that you gotta be will you really be
shy from the inside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they drop some hail on people hard
gonna go have dinner with my college
friends and family i thought it was
highly successful i feel like the vibe
is set i feel very confident about the
next several days pumped to be daily
feeling it again
and just thanks to the whole team and
everybody really appreciate it
please welcome
ceo and creator of be friends
gary vaynerchuk
my name is gary vaynerchuk series 2.
you guys gonna [ __ ] make content
that's the game
okay hold on one second [ __ ] bro who
the [ __ ] are you i'm gary v series three
who the [ __ ] are you dick
where the [ __ ] are you dude i'm the
[ __ ] series one [ __ ] series one [ __ ]
i love that [ __ ]
[Music]
you